I'm an undergraduate student of
chemistry and interested in research may
you please suggest scenario chemistry
which you are currently which are
currently more rewarding for a session I
really don't know the answer to that I'm
stepping backwards myself into trying to
understand carbon vapor a bit better and
so I can't really advise you all i can
say is to tell you what my experience
was and enough general level but not to
actually advise you on a specifics and
when I was a school as I said earlier I
got the book fees and fiza organic
chemistry I've been advice to get this
by my teacher Harry Heaney who later
became a professor of chemistry and I
read that book from carrots ago and I
really liked it was written it was it
was written as a bit of a read rather
than just organic chemistry as I if I
had any particular interest it was
organic chemistry when I went to
university and then I discovered our
lectures from Professor sheffield on
spectroscopy and from George Porter on
free free radical chemistry and flash
photolysis and I are pretty excited
about spectroscopy so I got diverted
into something which had a bit of
quantum mechanics and I was interested
in that too and I fell in love with that
subject a bit and then got the first
degree and pretty good one and I could
go on to do a PhD so I wanted to stay at
university to do the PhD but I wasn't
thinking of
from becoming a chemist a mate
particularly I I wanted to stay at
university because I had was I played
tennis for the University and I was on
the art editor for the magazine i was
doing lots of things and i didn't want
to stop I wanted to continue to do that
so I had three years as an undergraduate
in three years as a graduate student at
Sheffield and in fact became president
of athletics council so I had a bit of
student politics and friend of mine
taught me to play the guitar not very
well he told me very well but I didn't
learn very well but they played a bit
and sighs having a good time my about
the girlfriend who became my wife
Margaret Sam and so it was I wanted to
stay there so I stayed to do a PhD and I
I like spectroscopy and with Richard
Dixon who was a spectra ask was i did a
PhD and then home high had offers
several offers of jobs and one was of
the BBC to go into educational
television science television which was
interesting and they were interested but
I was already thinking of going abroad
to Canada to because I want to live
abroad to do a postdoc in spectroscopy
which I did and even then I coming back
and getting a job and then I was asked I
went to Bell Labs to do some more
research spectroscopic research and
theory and then came back to England to
a job a postdoc actually because I had
to get on to the guy back and then I was
offered a job in University and so it
was more than I just followed the things
that interested me at the particular
moment rather than some farsighted
aspect so my advice is whatever
situation is the present time what is it
that turns you on that you're interested
in that you're passionate about it why
is it that you will always put in a good
job never put in a second-rate job if if
you're doing something where you happy
satisfied with the second-rate job don't
do it do something else there you be
won't satisfy you all of your SATs
might've it's first-rate work as hot as
you can and you'll find that things will
open up rather than my telling you think
of the more the physical or the mental
attitude that you have to some of the
things that interest you at the moment
and find if they find them interesting
then maybe they are interesting to you
that's more important than interesting
to other people I found that if it's
interesting to everybody they're already
doing it and they've already done the
exciting stuff I tend to look at things
that interest me personally and follow
those lines with determination that's
perhaps one of the qualities i have have
a lot of determination i do things to
the best of my ability so no general
area is there something that turns you
personally on follow it through and see
where it leads you